is meant to be working in the developing
world and it's the majority of its
donations come from women the people
whose staff it's charity shops around
the world are middle-aged and elderly
women who almost all of them will
completely agree with JK Rowling stance
on all of this and are doing this work
because they care about the women who
die in childbirth they care about the
children who are starving they care
about the innocent victims of war
earthquake famine Etc so no I don't I
don't bend over backwards on this and I
say this as the mother of a gay son and
he'd agree with me their focus should be
on the half of humanity women who are
the innocent victims in these situations
they should be thinking about mothers
they should be thinking about babies and
they've lost their homes
it's just you know once you start down
this Rabbit Hole of thinking that men
are the world's most marginalized people
as long as those men think they're women
you've lost all touch with reality and
you turn yourself 180 degrees around
from what your original Mission was and
you start talking this sort of nonsense
and then you end up producing bigoted
propaganda like this